Bonjour tout le monde
et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo
alors pour la vidéo d'aujourd'hui ça va être un sujet
assez
intéressant je pense puisque on va parler de Duolingo
et en fait je vais vous expliquer, je vais vous donner
mon avis sur Duolingo
dans plusieurs
autres vidéos dans plusieurs autres
podcasts j'ai dit
plusieurs fois que je n'étais pas un grand fan de
Duolingo et je voulais dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui
expliquer plus en détail
pourquoi je ne suis pas un grand fan de Duolingo
je l'ai utilisé, j'ai utilisé l'application duolingo
pour le japonais
et le portugais
et je l'ai utilisé
pendant 3 4 mois je pense et j'avais même
souscrit à un abonnement familial et j'avais
invité mes parents et des amis
à me rejoindre pour apprendre des langues donc
j'ai une petite expérience avec l'application
je ne prétends pas
tout connaître de l'application
mais je pense pouvoir donner mon avis
sur son utilisation étant donné que
je l'ai utilisé pour le japonais
à un niveau intermédiaire
et je l'avais utilisé pour le portugais
à un niveau débutant
avant de commencer à donner mon
avis et si je regarde en bas c'est parce que
j'ai quelques notes
avant de commencer à donner mon avis
j'avais un disclaimer
qui est que ce qui est important c'est que vous
vous preniez plaisir à utiliser une méthode c'est que
ce qui est important c'est de travailler régulièrement
donc si vous aimez utiliser Duolingo
continuez d'utiliser l'application
ce n'est pas parce que vous regardez une vidéo YouTube
et que quelqu'un
dit que l'application est nulle
qu'il faut tout de suite arrêter
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas parce que vous regardez
une vidéo où quelqu'un
dit que une méthode une méthodologie pardon
est exceptionnel et super efficace
qu'il faut tout arrêter pour
aller faire cette méthodologie
faut prendre les choses avec un peu de recul
et si vous aimez utiliser
Duolingo continuez de l'utiliser
mais essayez de vous poser quand-même des questions
sur son efficacité savoir si ça vous convient toujours
d'utiliser l'application
si à un moment vous ressentez le besoin
d'essayer quelque chose d'autre
demandez-vous pourquoi
Duolingo n'est plus suffisant pour votre apprentissage
bien on peut commencer donc Duolingo
c'est l'application
d'apprentissage des langues la plus populaire au monde
il me semble
qu'il y avait une statistique
comme quoi ils ils avaient 90% des parts de marché
sur les applications
d'apprentissage des langues c'est-à-dire que les
parts de marché
c'est un peu le gâteau
que toutes les entreprises qui créent des applications
pour apprendre des langues se partagent et du coup
Duolingo a 90% du gâteau donc une sacrée part
à côté de ça il y a des applications comme
Babel Rosetta Stone et plein d'autres
mais je n'ai jamais utilisé d'autres applications
hormis Duolingo et hormis les applications
de flashcard comme Anki et autres
c'est l'application la plus populaire
c'est l'application
la plus utilisée
dans le monde
pour apprendre des langues et pourtant
je ne suis pas vraiment convaincu par Duolingo
je vais commencer
avec les points
positifs parce qu'il y en a et il y en a plusieurs
le premier point
très positif de l'application Duolingo
je trouve que c'est
que l'application encourage
les personnes qui apprennent des langues à étudier
un peu tous les jours
il y a notamment
les compteurs de jours les compteurs de séries
où quand vous êtes sur Duolingo pardon
tous les jours vous avez un compteur de jours
qui augmente si vous travaillez
tous les jours
et du coup ça c'est un peu au centre de l'application
où vous avez ce compteur
qui change de couleur qui change de dessin
chaque jour où vous travaillez
et ça encourage vraiment à revenir
régulièrement sur l'application
en plus de ça sur votre téléphone
vous allez avoir beaucoup de rappels de notifications
qui sont là pour vous dire étudie chaque jour
c'est important pour augmenter ton compteur
et ça ça peut paraître bête mais si
en fait ça fait le lien avec
un podcast que j'ai fait précédemment
qui est sur le pouvoir des habitudes
la clé du succès c'est de faire un peu tous les jours
si vous voulez vraiment progresser dans une langue
il faut travailler
un peu tous les jours
et du coup cette fonctionnalité
de Duolingo elle est hyper importante
puisque ça apprend ça
aux personnes qui
qui utilisent l'application
et quand on débute dans une langue ce n'est pas forcément
quelque chose avec lequel
on est très familier on a pas l'habitude on a pas
conscience
qu'il faut travailler
tous les jours comme ça et du coup c'est quelque chose
que Duolingo
sait très bien faire
et d'ailleurs quand j'ai des étudiants qui débutent
complètement en français
quand je commence à leur expliquer cette
notion d'habitude de travailler un peu tous les jours
si vraiment ils n'ont, ils ne l'ont jamais fait
je leur conseille
et c'est d'essayer un peu duolingo
pour voir comment ça fonctionne
pour voir comment juste avoir un compteur de jours
peut nous motiver à travailler un peu
tous les jours
le 2e point positif c'est que il y a
je crois une forme de SRS
un spaced repetition système c'est-à-dire que
quand il s'agit de mémoriser
de nouveaux mots de vocabulaire
l'idéal c'est qu'en fait on révise le mot et selon
si on se souvient ou pas du mot
on le révise dans plus ou moins longtemps
une application hyper populaire
en srs c'est Anki
Anki c'est une application
dans laquelle vous pouvez créer des cartes
sur tout et n'importe quoi il y a des étudiants
en médecine, en droit qui utilisent l'application
et il y a aussi toutes les personnes
qui apprennent des langues étrangères
donc ce système de répétition
espacé dans le temps
de révision espacée dans le temps
il est très important et ça pour ça Duolingo
est très efficace
je ne sais pas exactement comment il fonctionne
mais en tout cas quand vous
apprenez un nouveau
mot de vocabulaire
en général dans les leçons suivantes il vous repropose
ce mot de vocabulaire
pour voir si vous vous en souvenez
et ça c'est idéal
pour apprendre de nouveaux mots
3e point positif il y a la gamification donc
la gamification
bon c'est un mot
anglais que je prononce bien à la française
mais l'idée c'est de
de rendre l'apprentissage un peu comme un jeu
l'idée c'est que on soit un peu dans une sorte de
jeu vidéo et qu'on apprenne en même temps
et ça par exemple ça va être avec toutes les
tous les points d'expérience que vous allez gagner
au fur à mesure
dans le parcours
Il me semble qu'il y a des sortes de défis
pour gagner des coupes
des trophées ce genre de chose
et du coup ça l'application elle essaie de rendre
l'apprentissage
divertissant et c'est un point positif parce que ça
encourage à continuer
à continuer de jouer et d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant puisque
l'apprentissage
d'une langue parfois c'est un peu comme un jeu vidéo
il y a des jeux vidéos où
notamment dans les RPG les MMORPG
ou parfois il faut faire une action répétitive
il faut refaire souvent
régulièrement la même action pour à la fin avoir
un objet ou une récompense et finalement
l'apprentissage des langues c'est un peu pareil
c'est que tous les jours on refait un peu
la même action de manière répétitive
tous les jours on revoit nos flashcards etc
pour à la fin avoir cette récompense
donc ça il y a
il y a quand-même
un aspect très positif je trouve dans
dans l'application
ça va de pair
avec l'aspect social c'est-à-dire que dans Duolingo
là où quand on apprend en autodidacte
on est parfois un peu isolé
on se sent un peu seul dans notre coin
à apprendre une langue sur Duolingo
vous allez avoir
vous pouvez vous connecter avec vos amis
et vous allez avoir des classements des Ligues
ou quand vous gagnez de l'expérience vous pouvez
monter de Ligue vous progressez au classement
avec vos amis avec des
personnes inconnues sur internet
et ça c'est idem c'est très positif
ça motive vraiment à
revenir travailler un peu tous les jours à revenir
faire ses leçons
pour pouvoir montrer à ses amis
regarde je continue de progresser etc
donc ça c'est un autre point très positif et enfin
ce qui est bien aussi je trouve
c'est que dans chaque leçon
il y a toujours
l'écrit et l'audio donc vous avez toujours
cet audio
que vous entendez et du coup ça vous expose entre
guillemets à la langue que vous apprenez
c'est important d'écouter c'est important de lire
et il faut un peu tout varier en fait
et avec ça aussi je me rappelle
d'un exercice
en portugais où c'était vraiment un exercice
d'immersion c'est-à-dire que
il y avait un dialogue entre deux personnes
il y avait l'écrit et l'audio
on écoutait le dialogue enfin j'écoutais le dialogue
et après Duolingo me posait des questions
sur le dialogue sur le contenu du dialogue
typiquement
typiquement un tel personnage a perdu telle chose
ec et à la fin la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'a perdu monsieur untel
je résume très grossièrement mais voilà ça
je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très positif
et que ça se rapproche un peu de cet apprentissage
par l'immersion
que je fais moi-même
où voilà on essaie de s'habituer au maximum
à la langue que l'on veut apprendre
donc tout ça c'est vraiment les
aspects positifs de l'application
qui font que je pense que c'est une application vraiment
très utile
surtout quand on débute
en fait dans l'apprentissage d'une langue
mais maintenant il y a des points négatifs
j'ai dit en début de vidéo
que ce n'est pas une application
dont je suis très fan
et c'est notamment pour tous les points négatifs
que je vais vous présenter
premièrement en fait je trouve que c'est trop facile
et que ce n'est pas vraiment efficace
si on réfléchit
d'un point de vue business entre guillemets
Duolingo eux leur intérêt c'est que les gens
reviennent sur l'application
et qui passent du temps sur l'application
pour à la fin souscrire à un abonnement
payer un abonnement
pour que l'entreprise Duolingo gagne de l'argent
et en fait
cette facilité au bout d'un moment je trouve que
elle fait que l'application
ne devient plus vraiment efficace
j'ai l'impression que les gens
chez Duolingo se posent la question de
comment éviter un maximum
la difficulté
pour les apprenants comment éviter un maximum
que les apprenants ressentent de la frustration
afin qu'ils
passent un maximum de temps sur l'application
j'ai l'impression qu'ils se posent
cette question plutôt que de se demander
est-ce que les gens progressent vraiment
et ça en fait
c'est un problème
parce que au bout d'un moment quand on fait les choses
des choses trop faciles on ne progresse plus vraiment
et
bien sûr il il ne faut pas commencer
par faire des choses trop difficiles pardon
si on fait des choses trop difficiles
ce n'est pas efficace
mais en fait il faut que il faut qu'on
il faut pratiquer il faut
étudier il faut s'exercer avec des choses
un petit peu difficiles pour qu'on puisse apprendre
sans que ce soit trop frustrant
et si je prends un exemple dans l'application de
Duolingo c'est par exemple les puzzles
parfois vous allez avoir
une phrase dans la langue
que vous apprenez
et vous allez devoir mettre la traduction
dans votre langue
cette traduction vous allez la mettre avec des
des petits mots qui sont déjà disponibles
et vous devez les mettre dans l'ordre
vous devez sélectionner les mots que vous voulez
utiliser et les mettre dans l'ordre
là ça rend facile
l'exercice puisqu'on a pas à taper nous même
sur notre clavier
les mots donc c'est beaucoup plus rapide
mais par contre c'est
le problème c'est que parfois
ces puzzles ils sont en fait trop faciles et parfois
on a même pas besoin de regarder
la phrase dans la langue que l'on apprend
et on sait déjà comment
répondre tout simplement parce qu'on regarde les mots
proposés
et on sait déjà comment les mettre dans l'ordre
pour faire une phrase correcte
dans notre langue maternelle
et par exemple quand je faisais du japonais
parfois je commençais
juste par regarder les mots disponibles et je
parfois je pouvais même je pouvais faire
des phrases je pouvais répondre sans même regarder
la phrase en japonais
et du coup les réponses sont parfois évidentes
je me rappelle quelquefois il y avait des
je devais choisir entre
je vais chez le dentiste ou je vais chez le pomme
ce qui est complètement illogique et en fait
quand on voit
ça en fait on ne se pose même plus de question
on a même plus besoin de vraiment comprendre
la langue que l'on apprend
et en fait ça devient inefficace on a
l'impression de progresser parce qu'on gagne
de l'expérience
mais en fait on apprend pas grand-chose
idem bon ça c'est un sujet un peu plus sensible
mais il n'y a pas de grammaire
dans mes souvenirs il n'y a pas vraiment de grammaire
qui est expliqué
je pense que la raison c'est que la théorie c'est
ennuyant quand on vous met une page
de théorie à lire sur la langue une
règle de grammaire qui fait 10 lignes
en fait vous avez juste envie de fermer l'application
et ça Duolingo a envie d'éviter ça
la théorie c'est ennuyant mais
c'est utile
notamment quand on débute c'est important de
comprendre les règles de base
mais aussi à un niveau intermédiaire
parfois à un niveau intermédiaire
on va avoir des difficultés
et juste essayer de comprendre un peu la théorie
ça peut permettre de débloquer certains points alors
je n'encourage
jamais les étudiants
à apprendre des règles très spécifiques
mais parfois juste un petit peu de théorie
avec un peu de pratique ça peut permettre de débloquer
des problèmes de compréhension dans la langue
et enfin je trouve que ça manque de contexte
dans quand vous utilisez duolingo
vous avez que des phrases courtes tous les exercices c'est
des phrases courtes hormis
l'exemple de l'exercice
de l'immersion
que j'ai évoqué dans les points positifs
et qui est un exercice assez rare quand-même
je trouve qu'en fait
toutes les phrases proposées sont courtes
tout est hors
contexte et du coup on n'a pas vraiment de
de choses
vraiment naturelles on n'a pas un texte
complet ou on n'a pas un audio
plus long et si je compare
en fait avec ce que je fais sur cette chaîne YouTube
dans mes vidéos
j'essaie d'avoir un discours
le plus proche de la vraie vie entre guillemets
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai quelques notes
mais rien n'est scripté je fais tout en improvisation
pour que ce soit assez naturel parce que
vous avez beau apprendre des petites phrases
après dans la vie de tous les jours
les gens ils parlent
ils se perdent
dans leur phrase ils recommencent une phrase
ils arrêtent ils en recommencent un autre
et du coup si on n'est pas habitué un peu à ce
ce mix un peu ce labyrinthe on peut être perdu et
vous pouvez comprendre
très bien des petites phrases sur duolingo
mais dès que vous allez arriver dans un
dans un contexte plus réel
ça va être difficile parce que tout est un peu
mélangé et d'ailleurs
là je suis, je continue de parler
mais je sais même pas quand a débuté ma
quand à débuter ma phrase pardon
et quand elle va finir, elle va finir maintenant
mais du coup cet exemple c'est pour vous montrer
que en fait ça manque de contexte ça manque de
d'une immersion naturelle et
que ce soit dans un texte plus long
où vous allez apprendre
du vocabulaire
vraiment dans un
contexte précis
ou dans une discussion
plus naturelle dans une immersion plus naturelle
donc ça c'est vraiment pour les
points négatifs et en fait
si je devais résumer mon avis sur Duolingo
je pense que c'est une bonne application pour débuter
je le propose à des
étudiants qui débutent complètement pour essayer
de leur faire comprendre
le pouvoir des habitudes
l'importance de faire un petit peu chaque jour
mais en fait je pense que l'application devient
vite une fausse bonne idée une fausse bonne idée c'est
quelque chose
dont on a l'impression
que c'est une bonne idée mais qu'au fond
ce n'est pas une si bonne idée et qu'on se fait une fausse
impression de cette bonne idée
c'est une fausse bonne idée parce qu'en fait
toute la gamification
tout le côté social
au bout d'un moment ça nous donne
l'impression de progresser on a l'impression de
vraiment avancer dans la langue on monte de Ligue
on on finit des chapitres entiers sur la langue
mais en fait notre progression
au fond elle n'est pas vraiment si importante
on apprend du vocabulaire
mais ça s'arrête là
et on est toujours à travailler
sur des petites phrases et
quand on doit passer sur un contexte plus naturel
en fait on est perdu
il y a pas mal de personnes qui font des vidéos en mode
j'ai fini
duolingo dans telle langue est ce que je peux parler
et cetera bon
il y a toujours un certain biais
il y a toujours la question de
quand on fait beaucoup d'immersion de compréhension
c'est ça reste toujours difficile de passer
à l'expression
de commencer à parler
souvent on comprend beaucoup mieux la langue
que on peut parler
mais voilà je pense qu'au fond Duolingo
c'est une fausse bonne idée et que
il faut réussir à se poser la question
au bout d'un moment de
est-ce que j'ai envie de continuer
avec cette application
est-ce que la manière dont j'apprends actuellement
Est-ce que c'est efficace
si je sens que j'ai besoin d'autres choses
pour progresser
ensuite il faut se poser la question de comment faire
ce que je recommanderai
personnellement c'est de
si vous êtes complètement
débutant c'est de commencer avec duolingo
créer une habitude
et quand vous commencez à avoir cette habitude
de travailler un peu tous les jours
basculer sur de l'immersion
plus classique
mais bon je dis ça dans une vidéo d'immersion
donc je pense que vous avez déjà l'habitude
de faire ça mais voilà
c'est un peu pour vous expliquer mon opinion
mon avis sur Duolingo
j'avais envie d'essayer d'être le plus
mesuré possible d'être le plus juste
donc voilà ma réponse c'est un peu
c'est une fausse bonne idée ce n'est pas très
tranché comme opinion
mais voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
si ça vous intéresse je pourrais continuer de parler
de méthodologie dans l'apprentissage des langues
après j'ai aussi envie de faire du contenu plus
sur la culture française ou plus
sur un aspect
divertissement
mais vous verrez ça par la suite
si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un like et un commentaire
à vous abonner
aussi à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait
merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout et je vous dis
à la prochaine